at this refugee center in warsaw
victoria flix passed photos on her phone
of her family's home in mariopol or what
was left of it the day she got out of
the city much has changed in nearly two
months of war and not much is left of
her city
we cry we all have the feeling that
we've no home
we've no idea where to go what to do
where to run it's very scary
more than half of ukrainian refugees are
in poland and the government is figuring
out how to accommodate even more but
officials wonder when the system will
break we see the escalation in southern
and eastern ukraine and there are seven
million ukrainians already displaced in
ukraine so of course that poses a
problem what if another wave comes and
here we need
international and european solutions we
need a system in place because otherwise
it will be very very difficult to absorb
more refugees
it's hard to describe the enormity of
the situation
a man-made catastrophe for the ukrainian
people or to grasp the heartache felt by
the women and children who've had to say
goodbye to husbands and
and dad will be selling things and
helping our heroes our army he might
even fight
[Music]
we've seen a quarter of ukraine's
population um more than 12 million
people in total including around 5
million refugees but also about 7.1
million people inside the country have
been forced to flee their homes so this
is a staggering amount of people that
are um have had to leave their their
homes their possessions in some cases
family members behind
so millions of families and millions of
lives have been shattered and their
lives have been torn apart by by this
war
with each new arrival a tale
of survival from what's become the
fastest displacement crisis in europe
since the second world war
andrew chappelle al jazeera